you
how to delight customers my goal is to
delight my own family of customers just
like my dad did for his Lu at your hand
founder of last minute training Lu at
your hand had a problem he's in a boring
industry Luise company last minute
training sells training for office
workers most people don't think about
training until they need it and it's
really hard to get people excited and
talking about it most people see
training as a necessary evil
not something to look forward to when
was the last time you went around
telling everyone you know about that
amazing excel training you just can't
wait to take exactly but with my help we
realize that he doesn't really sell
training he sells the experience of
being delighted his one word is delight
and he built his entire business around
it he delights his customers by actually
caring about them can his team research
and know more about all the training
options available than any other
competitor so he can give the best
recommendations to his clients he knows
which training providers deliver the
highest quality training for each
subject area who is least likely the
cancer plastid and who has the best
learning environment for his customers
he often books people in the course ago
he makes less money because it's the
right thing for the clients when he
interviews new staff members he first
looks at whether they have an attitude
of delighting people before he looked at
their skills experience or references in
his marketing he shows a picture of his
baby son smiling because he wants people
to feel delighted when they see his ad
the results when I first met Louie and
he joined my mastermind group he had
just an idea on paper it was a pure
startup fast forward a few years and
Louie now has an office a team branding
client tells over 10,000 training
classes and is booked almost 10 million
dollars in business he's making money
and making an impact so I asked Lee to
share how he found his one word
it was over 20 years ago but I can still
remember it like it was yesterday I woke
up on Christmas morning wondering where
Dad was he was gone because it was cold
outside I mean really cold like 50 below
and another family needed him to come
fix their broken furnace he was the
furnace repairman and these were his
customers dad always went above and
beyond to help a customer even if they
were total strangers especially on
Christmas this wasn't the first or last
holiday without him dad hated seeing
people suffering I could tell you story
after story where he aimed to bring joy
and relief to the people around him in
every moment often at his own expense or
his family and now I understand we were
all family to him every person now my
goal is to delight my own family of
customers just like my dad did for his I
can't help it it's ingrained in me it's
part of my DNA and let's be honest you
probably rarely think of scheduling
training as a delightful experience in
reality is probably a huge headache most
of our clients tell us they would
previously spend hours and hours
researching and then booking and
managing multiple vendors for a variety
of different training classes only to
get inadequate or even canceled classes
we screen the vendors and trainers for
quality making sure we understand your
needs to get you the right training plus
we negotiate the deal for you our staffs
can often find you the right training
class in minutes where it might take you
days to complete the search for the
right class on your own I built an
entire team made up of people who just
like my dad will bend over backwards to
delight you it wouldn't matter what kind
of business I'm in my number one
priority would still be to delight my
customers
you
you